and even in the cities in California
yeah I mean the airbag vest or jacket is
I mean they have a tether or system the
whole point is and they also have a
version for horseback riders would have
saved Christopher Reeves what it turns
you into the Stay Puft Marshmallow your
skin on broken fractured or whatever I
mean of course it's not gonna save me
from being switched I cannot like long
you know sure but still it's just
another safety measure but I've seen
videos of like demonstrations of it and
they're also like news clips of people
who have their say
that's great that's a great yeah that's
a great invention yeah well doesn't seem
like and you have the jacket oh yeah oh
that's great I had the jacket version
how heavy is that it's funny because
like the Americans so they know what it
is something else you don't look like a
like a flux capacitor because it's
basically sudden they have no clue
whether they have no included but it
basically does have a co2 canister so
then it just like was up the entire life
I got the gun by the videos that
thinking that oh yeah it's awesome
because they had like a stunt drivers
fly off the bike
[Music]
yeah I had the little Honda Magna 750
and drilled out the baffles I was to
make it sound like a Harley Princess
cruise up the timing and everything but
it sounded great right it sounded great
it was it was a fun it was a fun ride my
dad had a Honda Hawk back in late 1979
by Canadian did that have the radiator
in front as well yes that is just so
amazing to me
really
we cannot believe that somebody did not
see how we said the window down and
either like if somebody slammed on the
brake and hit somebody yeah you go to
the beach with your surfboard for us we
ride in the back of a truck going down
the freeway
Magne she was like listening
reminder
[Music]
at eleven okay and she's in the green
get your questions
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
well
[Music]
[Music]
good morning morning good morning it is
Supreme Court decision holding President
Obama's wonderful action to support I
think the doctor decision is something
that ports our values of the country the
dreamers across the countries enjoy a
more popular than almost anyone
overwhelmingly it's something like 75 80
percent of the American people
three-quarters of the people who both
support the dreamers who porters a large
number of Republicans independent people
whose it's over 60 percent people
support president Trump's approach so
this is it really we were in just in
such a read that what could possibly
happen at the court up until last night
just if it goes this way if it goes that
way but this way is the American Way we
were very proud of it so that means this
morning last night and the Judiciary
Committee late last night the committee
overwhelmingly passed out of the George
Boyd justice and policing act which will
now go to rules and then come to the
floor before the fourth of July we're
very proud of the work that was done by
jerilyn Karen bass the chair of the
Judiciary Committee but also the chair
of the crime subcommittee
the Judiciary Committee morning the
Supreme Court and danke last night
the Judiciary Committee and that justice
in policing that tomorrow is Juneteenth
a day that we observed as a day of in
our country but the day and the people
in the West found out about the
Emancipation Proclamation in observance
of that I had sent a letter she will say
to the clerk of the house directing the
other Clerk to remove the portraits of
four previous speakers of the house he
served in the Confederacy if we don't
know about this until we replace the
inventory of the statues and they've
sorry they're told us that there were
four paintings of speakers in them and
the capitol of the United States four
speakers who had served in the
Confederacy so of tomorrow Jim King the
clerk will oversee removal of those
Confederate speakers from the house as
I've said before there's no room in the
hallowed halls of this democracy
to memorialize people who embody violent
bigotry and grotesque racism other than
letters you have to see the remarks that
they had made and how oblivious they
were to what our founders had in mind in
our country we must lead by example so
we're glad that that is gone the I'll
take some questions at a moment about
the Justice in policing Act but we are
very proud of the legislation that was
put together it would work decades the
fills have been in the hopper for a
while but in terms of the public
sentiment to get the job done in a
strong way the moment it's now as we
take action on their justice in the and
policing we also have to recognize other
injustice in our country what its
injustice in health care in the economy
and environmental injustice that exists
the list goes on and one man at the
station of it right now is the girl
having a disparate impact on people of
color in our context and so we're hoping
and pushing and advocating for the
passage of the Kiros act open our
economy testing tracing treating
isolating get the job done we don't have
we don't have a vaccine and we don't
have a cure
hopefully we will and that science will
be the answer to our prayers in that
regard
but we do have testing tracing treatment
and we want you to address that in a way
that demonstrate impact on people of
color in our country so that we can save
their lives so if we can save their life
or the legislation also has an impact on
our economy and yesterday on the day and
the day before the chairman of the Fed
joram Powell urged Congress not to take
our foot off the brake I would think it
would be of concern to Congress if
Congress were to pull back on the
support that it is providing too quickly
I do think it would be appropriate to
think about continuing support for
people who are newly out of work and for
smaller businesses who are struggling
the economy is not just now beginning to
recover is a critical phase and I think
the support would be well
at this time he's not the only one
movies yesterday
the economic forecasting for Moody's
published an analysis that highlights
the need for the heroes Act quote
without additional help from Congress
and the administration prospects for
double-digit unemployment throughout the
end of next year and even this assumes
nothing else goes wrong like a serious
second wave of the virus how well the
economy does in the next several years
depends critically on what lawmakers
decide to do in the next few weeks and
in the next few weeks we are hoping that
as you've seen they went from never
we're not doing another bill to well
maybe but not so big and maybe but not
so soon and you see they're having their
own internal debate about the size and
scope and timing of what happens next
but we must help our honor our heroes
help our state and local governments
I've told you before Speaker gov slash
heroes Act to see what it means to you
in your community open our economy
testing of tracing feelings and
isolation and direct payments
they have it has been said by economists
including secretary chairman of course
we want our voting vote-by-mail alleged
money in there as well so two month
later today not here but in the Rayburn
room
House Democrats will unveil a chart to
the moving forward act taking bold
transformational action to build the
infrastructure of America while again
addressing keys and justices justice of
transportation and transit in the wreck
sadly the koban 19 crisis has laid bare
many vulnerabilities and disparities in
our nation in terms of health care
financial security housing
transportation and more which we will
combat with this legislation Democrats
plan will protect families health great
jobs grow the economy invest in clean
energy and climate resilience and ensure
that America's and district
is the envy of the world we'll bring
this bill to the floor and pass it
before the fourth of July and with that
lower the cost of prescription drugs
lower the cost of health care by
lowering the cost of prescription drugs
and preserving the pre-existing
condition that bill will once again 429
[Music]
the next day maybe I'll take two days
there's over one health care cause
bigger paychecks by building the
infrastructure of America that will be
the next two days and before that making
our government better with the justice
and policing Act which I begin
that any question go figure on the
police reform bill is getting a little
bit ahead of things but I know you're
very proud of your bill the Senate
Republicans introduced tears
can you imagine what you support ending
up in conference on this and it is a
limited and on you can do to effect what
the Senate's gonna do but if you can
move things in parallel
well we end up in conference because
that's how Congress works it's well the
house acts for Senate acts and a go to
conference and try to reconcile the
legislation it's so important the
American people care so much they know
so much they are watching and this is an
opportunity that we have never had
before as you can see taking all kinds
of shape in terms of setting the record
straight as to who we are as a country
and how we treat people and so again my
ago she aters our count led by Karen
bass and Jerry Nadler the chair of the
Judiciary Committee and I'm very proud
of the work that they have done it's
very different in terms of what it does
then the Senate
but at least they have similar
categories flip to that end in your
conversations with leaders Schumer
you're encouraging him to let that
Senate bill move forward to ultimately
get to that point one of the things you
should know about our interaction is
they don't tell me what you're doing I
heads up to the Senate to make their own
decisions that how they go forward but
we do have a bill that is introduced in
the house and in the Senate we're very
proud of the work also of Senator Booker
and Xander Harris is and sort of embrace
of legislation between now and the
election well we would like to pass the
DREAM Act the dream and promise and
which goes well beyond dhaka to many
more dreamers it goes for TPS Sandberg's
tested status DVD a deferred enforcement
kind of provision so we would like to
see that bill pass what we really like
though is to come together to talk about
the comprehensive immigration reform
that goes even well beyond the
legislation I just talked about but
there isn't anybody in the immigration
community that wants us well we did pass
a bill it's called the DREAM Act you
know whatever the problem as a
compliment
well well well see I mean there had been
times when the president has said that
he would support bipartisan
comprehensive immigration reform right
there on TV and the White House with
Democratic and Republican members of
Congress that are House and Senate there
and then renamed on it so what we'll see
I mean it would be great if we could do
that it's what we really need to do for
our country there was bipartisan support
in the Senate for such a bill which the
Senate Republican House Republicans
would not allow to be brought up in the
house so it isn't as if we haven't
common ground we can but there's not
much time Honda poison 130 well let's
hope for the best and always try to find
that but I don't I don't I don't know
what's president meant maybe he doesn't
either because he said before in the
house and you be willing to subpoena him
if necessary well if it isn't
interesting because he was so arrogant
in terms of the house of when we were
engaged in the impeachment we did
impeach the president of United States
removing him from office requires a
bullet of the Senate and they have said
that there is many of them have said
there's nothing that John Bolton has put
forth will change their mind that
removing the president from office
because no matter how unfit the
president is they just did not want a
Democratic president President Trump by
dint of what we saw in the impeachment
by what others are being quoted as
saying in terms of leaders in the
president didn't is on
administration President Trump is
clearly ethically unfit and
intellectually unprepared to be the
president of the United States that
doesn't seem to matter to the
Republicans in the United States Senate
didn't seem to matter to John Bolton he
chose royalty over put over patriotism
and and and so it's going to make money
off of his book I guess I thought will
make the judgment all be really wicked
tears to make a judgment because it's
not necessarily about whether in
subpoena or what we did subpoena some of
his employees and they very courageously
testify some of the people who worked
with them very previously testified as
mister shipp statement mister shipp put
out a very strong statement I call it to
your attention eliot engel the chair of
the Foreign Affairs Committee put out a
very strong statement on this and we'll
be discussing how the American people
are best served by oversight the public
has a right to know as you know we're
waiting for the court to decide maybe by
the end of this month as to whether they
will support what our founders had in
mind the separation of powers three
separate coequal branches of government
each a check and balance on the other
that is what is at stake and they
for the Supreme Court now when it comes
to subpoenas being respected by the
executive branch so I think abbreviate
one thing is for sure American people
have a right to know our oversight will
always continue whether that's by
subpoena
some other way of discuss that with the
chairs of the committees in the Nicene a
book by a microblog that was a
substitute for testifying before
Congress about the well-being of the
American people no I'm very proud of
what we did a decision decisions were
made it's over somebody who's trying to
keep the con going with the white wing
of the Republican Party by criticizing
us for not subpoena in him when he said
he wouldn't come in you know he'd go to
the Senate where that we knew the Senate
would not have subpoena him so this is
this is called a con and we are very
proud of what we have done and it's
really a sad thing because he knew that
the president should be removed from
office that's clear and he doesn't want
to keep his ties to the right wing so he
does that box for the sides enough I
place no value on that I repeat
president talk clearly evidence is clear
it always has been
president Trump is ethic
unfit into an intellectually unprepared
to be President of the United States yes
sir I kind of figure related a little
bit fourth chatted asked you about these
sort of big moments that Congress's
Facebook or whether it be immigration
gun violence or deficit reduction we
have seen these moments where it seems
like there's a lot of buy-in for a
common cause only hurt the fall apart at
the end and I'm curious your level of
confidence on police reform given that
this appears to be one of those moments
well you know go back to Abraham Lincoln
public sentiment is everything with it
you can accomplish almost anything
without it practically nothing now
you've heard me say that before again
and again and it is affect and public
sentiment well from public sentiments
away in the public has to know and that
is sometimes
I really know what the choice is do they
do they do they have made feel beautiful
patriotically piece and for the Congress
of the United States to ignore that call
for justice would be wrong so I have
confidence that something will happen
now because it must because the people
insist and they're not going to stop
insisting until we get until we get
something done I swear the back to the
police reform bills for analysis I am
sorry about that dude there we go
it's like to be a police reform bills
for a moment since some of the reactions
from law enforcement I'm over in Los
Angeles there's been a reaction and
apparently so much officers did not show
up to a work over at the MTA over in
Atlanta we're hearing that officers to
be report to work there is there concern
about blue flu essentially happening
across the country in reaction to what
we're seeing up here on Capitol Hill as
well as locally I think that the men
women in volute or whether that's
firefighters there in blue who I think
but our men and women in blue there are
none of them there to keep the American
people safe who care about doing their
jobs in a way that honors just
and I we had communication with the
Fraternal Order of Police connected them
with soup with Karen bass so that she
could hear some of their concerns and we
think that there's a place for us to
come together we do know that there are
some people who as we've seen their
actions that are not I think everybody
who wears blue would be proud of those
ads but I do think there many people in
the world whose actions we aren't proud
of and I think there are enough of them
[Music]
well what would they want to do if we
take out the state and local government
money which is absolutely essential by
the end of June many states and
localities have to have their budgets
balanced but the very person who doesn't
even care
that really really you don't care about
the back of saving local governments
meet the needs of people need to have
their balance budgets balanced and this
is money that is needed for them to pay
for they're caught the cost of the
Colonna virus to them their outlays of
money to meet the needs and they lost a
revenue Nathan needs lots of revenue on
the coronavirus testing testing testing
are they willing to help the states to
test in a way that fights this fight
this virus defeats this buyers why would
we divide those two because they are
directly connected and what piece would
they want would they want to do they say
they don't want to do unemployment
insurance this is the 13th week that
we've had over a million people applying
for unemployment they're straight
so what piece would would you subtract
this is a very disciplined focused
necessary piece of legislation honor our
heroes support state local open our
economy tax when facing treatment money
in the pockets of the American people I
think they're all very connected and
should go forward together I haven't
seen any initiative when there pothen
seeing them say we should help state and
local I feel better than the Senate had
I haven't seen anybody in the house like
that
I haven't seen any of them say we really
need to test so that we can address this
comprehensively addressing the disparity
in all this and I have heard someone say
they don't want to do anymore
unemployment insurance identify all the
same things I just mentioned they are
all stimulus to the economy they're all
stimulus to the economy because I have
to say it all the time the one piece
state local government bigger dot burns
like heroes that go look it up this hat
cost of what the Republicans did in
their tax
which gave 83% of the benefits to the
top 1% do not provide any stimulus to
the economy and huge two trillion
dollars of debt point charge our
children so perhaps what they were
willing to do but high well I want to do
for the whole country and at the same
time honor
IRA our heroes I wonder if you you said
you don't like the Republican bill but
you at least the categories seem the
same on the policing reform or you
indicated that I wonder if you see more
urgency here on police reform than you
saw on you know kind of the gun question
or an any number of other bills that the
Senate has not taken up I mean at least
we're both working on the same topic I
wonder if that's no good for you at all
well the issue is apparently yesterday
was a five-year and
that terrible shooting when that young
man wedding there prayed with people and
then shot them dead and then shot them
yet so carrying that around for that
long time but memorializing it again
yesterday so the gun issue is a very
important issue and it's one that it's
very background check legislation
including mystic sightings South
Carolina it is it's important to us and
like 80% of American people support that
including gun owners who have to have
background checks and and they do comply
with that and support that legislation
we haven't seen tens of thousands of
in the streets day in and day out over a
long period of time a message that
spread throughout the world about
justice about justice
so that demonstration in the streets was
about this issue that police brutality
but also about fairness just fairness
across the board and when you're talking
about brutality and you're talking about
safety you're talking about guns - so
that's continuous to be a very important
issue for us but you would have to admit
and it's quite obvious to all of us that
we have not ever seen anything quite
like the peaceful demonstrations that
are out there awakened by the visible
strangulation mentioned choke hold
a Jewish boy
and the reaction of people had - it
wasn't the first time it happened that
many times but I think just somehow or
other day before
Cantus close by saying what I've said to
you before me and we we had Bryan
Stevenson we talked to him about he had
20 Museum in Alabama many of us were
just there in March and when you coach
it he has two ones up like a monument
and the other ones are from you soon we
build a museum
it's about flavory and semester that and
I bring it up again because as a mom
that just impressed me so I have my
grandson with me when we saw this there
are two little children on the wall
they're slaves and they speak and they
say mama mama the middle children mama
mama
if anyone seen my mother does anyone
know our mother
of course you know the mother has been
separated from the children and the
brutality of all of that and then here
George Floyd format for his mother just
call the humanity of it all I think the
public just struck such a chord for many
reasons not just the Marmont part but
the part of 8 minutes and 46 seconds
somebody fed a number of times
I can't believe in humanity of it all I
think has taken us to a place where you
won't get we will have justice we won't
have a bill I hope that is sooner rather
than later thank you
[Music]
will you a favor done
[Music]
[Music]